hey what's up folks welcome back to
gamespot at e3 2016 I'm very happy to be
joined by Taylor Kurosaki narrative
director at infinity ward sir pleasure
to have you here thanks Danny we're here
to talk about call of duty infinite
warfare correct it was wonderful seeing
some of the single-player action
yesterday I'm a big quality fan going
back recent years like a lot of people
have sort of like waned a bit on the
single player stuff and playing mostly
multiplayer and but seem like there's a
really great sort of breath of fresh air
in what we saw in terms of the gameplay
and what's it like having people react
to that it's been great it's been great
we've been waiting to show to show some
gameplay to the fans and I'm just glad
we finally got to put it out there and
the reactions have been great yeah we
really wanted to put a push on on the
single-player component of the game and
really put a focus on narrative you know
we really want to tell a deep
character-driven story about war I mean
war is such an incredibly rich genre
working and so really what we were going
for is the story of leadership and the
burden of leadership in most shooters
you are playing as the new guy right in
this game you're playing as a captain
you are in command of the UN sa carrière
retribution and you have thousands of
crew that you are leading into battle on
a on a terribly dire de where the the
very survival of the earth is threatened
by an implacable enemy the settlement
Defense front war stories are difficult
to do I mean often video games
trivialize for quite a bit there you
know some games have to attempted to
sort of jump into the other side like
spec ops the line for instance how did
you come to sort of tackle this I guess
pushing this into the future sort of
does distance yourself from the burden
of responsibility somewhat but yeah
somebody who's like your core sort of
job is to talk a bit to write a story
about what is essentially the worst
possible human thing and what is what's
the sort of challenge with that have you
figured out it sure well we don't think
we sidestepped anything with with our
setting our setting is really there to
give us some really incredible new
gameplay opportunities and some new
mechanics that we just couldn't do if we
were limited to two
round right but in terms of the story
and talking about war I mean what war is
is it's an incredible pressure it puts
incredible pressures on people and how
they react to those pressures reveals
their true character so we're not
sidestepping it we're not trivializing
it these are soldiers that is their job
that's what they do and how they respond
to these pressures that are put on them
in the course throughout the course of
the game is what's really interesting
you know as far as we're concerned how
they how they interact with their crew
and how they you know how they get
through this what's it like are you guys
working on one single protagonist system
around I mean yes you are what's that
been like because I mean a lot of the
game you know it's not you guys have
done it before in recent years as well
but you know oftentimes the war stories
can be more easily told with different
perspectives sure so what type of so are
you telling this time right well our
story is totally focused on the burden
of leadership you like I said you're the
captain you have thousands of crew at
your at your command and and you have to
not just fight for the guy next to you
which is a very very common theme in war
stories in this case the the mission
comes first that is the theme the
mission above all comes first and that
is the burden that only a true leader
has to feel are we looking at some of
this yeah yes so hot action right here
this is some of the stuff we showed last
night at the sony press conference and
what it's really showing you is you get
to choose where your carrier goes mmm i
think that we're really pushing on is if
we're going to tell story about
leadership well you've got to be a
leader and if you're going to be a
leader that means making choices right
and making decisions and one of those
key decisions you get to make is choose
where your carrier goes You certainly
have missions that are that are given to
you by command but you ultimately get to
choose when you do those missions and
and when you put your carrier out there
to take on enemy ships targets of
opportunity and so forth so it's not a
directly linear game then there's some
element of agency within that story
there is there is we are we're telling a
very very deep emerge
narrative that requires that it's an
authored experience so the overall arc
is linear but yet you do have choice to
take on side missions and you can learn
more about the enemy you can learn more
about the crew that you that you play
alongside you can steal enemy tech you
can again this is a devastating sneak
attack on earth and so the retribution
has not had time to resupply so you're
just scraping and clawing and trying to
find every edge you can get to win this
war is a lot of that stuff is a kind of
come in the form of like optional side
missions or missions within missions how
does it kind of work it's uh there's a
lot of optional side missions that the
player can choose to undertake or not
and we really feel that having that
choice is what really gives people that
feeling of leadership we want to put you
in those boots I'm alright in hearing
the kit harington is the untag honest in
this game he is one of the faces okay
enemy yes what's up and like working oh
he is he's great he's great he I think
he was really excited to finally get to
play a villain right yeah apparently
doesn't like being a heartthrob much not
something I talk isn't it yeah I know
you and I guess you know how difficult
you've worked on you know uncharted mana
you came from Naughty Dog you've been
sort of inserted into IW to help them
tackle sort of adding story to i mean
you know they've always in rich single
player experiences in the call of duty
and franchise but what has it been your
sort of your biggest I guess challenge
and trying to add rich story to call
duty because these are essentially games
a bad moment to moment bombast lose but
how do you find the time to tell a story
with in there but there's essentially
creating just long cutscenes between
each level sure well you you have to
make the time but ultimately the bombast
and the set pieces in the action moments
you talk about that's what's so exciting
about being able to tell a story in the
call of duty universe those moments are
so incredible and those and so
spectacular that if we can infuse real
characters that you care about into
those scenarios then those moments are
going to just play even better do you
think the players going to empathize
with the earth that is happening like
how far in the future we talking about
what's what's happening within this
earth economy that's causing this
problem on it uh well what's happening
is we have reached the end of being able
to sustain the earth from the materials
that the earth provides we are out of
and this is all real stuff you know in
50 years people say we're going to be
out of things like tin mmm and you need
those kinds of materials to make
semiconductors for example and so our
jumping-off point for the story was what
happens how does the earth continue to
sustain itself when some of those rare
earth materials have have have been used
up and it's been said that the first
trillionaire will be the person who
successfully mines an asteroid right
yeah and brings those materials back to
earth and so when you have that kind of
money at stake and those kinds of steaks
right uh the the lifeblood of life on
Earth there's going to be crime there's
going to be greed and there's going to
be conflict and so that seemed like the
perfect scenario to to set our game in
how far ahead in the future are we
talking about we're not talking about a
specific okay the thing is when you talk
about a specific year you'll ask one
person how far in the future do you
think this is and they'll say 20 years
yeah let's go the person he says it's a
thousand years so you can never ever get
it right and so in the same way that's
in the same great history of people like
James Cameron you just don't talk about
in there it's happening so I guess the
question I have in relation to is do
cultures as we understand them today
still exist yes there are the Europeans
and Americans yes because that's often a
thing that in future sci fi those little
touches make you sort of connect with
characters in a way that you wouldn't
otherwise yeah I mean the big thing is
sure we're not talking about the year
that it takes place in but it's going to
be a relatable recognizable earth that
you're gonna see see touchstones of in
in our future and our crew of the
retribution this crew that captain Reyes
has to lead it's made up of people from
all different nations all different
cultures and backgrounds and they are
all united together against this common
foe so we have people from Great Britain
with people from well we have an Irish
yes underrepresented green
love it corporal Brooks ok I'll I by the
lovely Jason Barry wonder he's an
incredible actor and an incredible
member of our cast and and he truly am
you know embodies a soldier's soldier
you know he's a guy you want fighting
next to you when when the settlement
Defense front decides to attend I
genuinely get a thrill whenever does an
hourish character it doesn't happen very
often so I appreciate it I think you're
gonna like this one and what else you
got to be teasing out over the next
couple of months it was great to see the
single player I mean people are starting
to get context for what this is in terms
of the characters I mean ultimately
people never really connect with the
characters until they played play the
game yeah everybody gonna be teasing out
over the next couple of months as we
sort of well an excellent big thing is
going to be cod XP Ryan returning back
to Cod XP without the first one yeah
that great city like yeah it was I did
it was actually I was way better than I
was expecting it was so it was so sort
of directed to the fans and also it was
weird to have Kanye West and dropkick
murphys play on the same stage we're in
light of each other yeah it was cool it
was paintball and oh it's gonna be it's
going to be awesome it's a September
second through the 4th at the forum in
los angeles and i can guarantee you it's
going to be an incredible experience and
we're going to talk a lot more about
multiplayer and about zombies and all of
that stuff they're awesome dedeker sake
thank you so much for coming on stage
and talking to us about quality duty
infinite warfare thanks Danny appreciate
your time all right you stick around you
got loads more games coming up Dominic
Guay from ubisoft is coming on stock
over bed watchdogs to and just a minute
so stick around we'll be back in a
second
you